after three long crowdless years the
pride and joy of competitive Siege the
six Invitational has returned in Earnest
I was there and dare I say
it was worth the wait from Scrappy and a
underdog runs to Brazilian overlords to
Fabian once again hoisting the hammer SI
2023 was the stuff that dreams are made
of
let's talk
[Music]
foreign
I just want to very quickly say that we
have merch head to
shop.thescore.com head over to the
Esports collection and check out our
hoodies and t-shirts in a bunch of cool
different colorways okay there's a lot
to talk about so let's dive into it this
past weekend the six Invitational
returned to Montreal Canada and opened
up its doors to the adoring public for
the first time in three years and in
that time A lot has happened with Siege
most of which isn't great despite being
regarded as a tier one esport
immediately following the last
Invitational a chaos of circumstances
came together to just absolutely
obliterate any semblance of steam Siege
was picking up kovid everything moving
online the game being in an awful State
balance and infrastructure wise
valarante coming out poor viewership
declining player numbers orgs leaving
Etc and it just really hurts to say it
all out loud like that eh the point is
that going into this tournament Siege
and specifically Siege Esports was in a
really tough spot honestly we just we
needed something to believe in again and
holy
did we get every stage of this event was
insane the group's matchups were so
competitive that the days went on
forever and some of the teams who looked
like they were going to dominate early
on ended up petering out towards the end
we had gauntlets Grudge matches upsets
and everything in between matches and
moments that will go down in Siege
history as first-rate bangers a pivot
has to happen from Koi with 15 seconds
or that's the map leaving iconic and
shuttle to deal with this Advance
diffuser in the hands of Leon kids
shuttle playing this small angle he
needs to pop up iconic softened up oh
we'll need to clutch he's fled to it all
and he gets all of them they're not
moving in he sees the shoulder of one
it's a post plan caught by the oryx one
new one
Leon gains to save his team
[Applause]
homie that entire astralis versus koi
series was just [__]
anyway aside from astralis's insane
Cinderella run we had oxg's long awaited
glow up w7m channeling their inner 2020
nip and the triumphant return of siege's
one true God emperor
want in my entire six months here but
what the [__] are we doing we're
teammate we're not talking we're
shouting over each other hey wake up
if they tell me when I go out of the
tournament we've shunned everyone here
that we were the best team in this
tournament in group stages do it you
guys got this communication and
coordination we're one by one dying
everywhere
time to wake up after that speech G2
went on to win 15 of their next 17 maps
and indeed the entire tournament is he
rushing in G2 looking to accomplish this
one kill away and it's Forbes to die
a new generation pick up where Legends
left off so yeah Fabian six months ago
this dude was an analyst on the eul desk
now he's hoisting his third Hammer with
G2 the very org on which he cemented his
legacy animation bro he'll lift the
hammer again
Fabian plus G2
they're inevitable aren't they ladies
and gentlemen you'll remember six
twenty twenty three
world champions
it's G2
if there was ever a story that could
awaken CG Sports from its Slumber is
this one it doesn't matter what region
you hail from there is something that
every Siege fan can appreciate about
Fabian clawing his way back to the top
and proving that he is undoubtedly the
goat it's not for me anymore it's to
show everyone else that I still got it
and to prove to the world that hey this
guy was the leader and he was the number
one there was nobody better than me Troy
you can go yourself I don't care I
literally want to beat everyone and I
can't do it and I know I can just give
me the right players and I'll do
anything that they ask me that said
every region had something that they
could rally behind except APAC you guys
had a bit of a rough one next year but
yeah I don't think it's a coincidence
that the final three rosters each hailed
from one of siege's three major regions
the competition was very stiff and it
will undeniably be an SI to remember
speaking of remembrance I do just want
to take a beat and try to convey just
how special it felt to be back in this
side I think I speak for the entire
Community when I say that it felt like a
reunion of sorts seeing all the
competitors creators and random everyday
fans after all that time away ended up
being cathartic in ways that I really
didn't anticipate I don't know what the
future holds for competitors each what I
do know is that amidst all of the
turmoil and uncertainty created by an
influx of orgs leaving came one of the
sickest and most organically engaging
events in the history of the game I know
it's anecdotal but I saw a bunch of the
same sheepish excited little 16 year
olds walking around this event that I
did back in 2020 that means that three
years of down in the doldrum Siege
wasn't enough to deter them they stuck
with the game that's really important I
can honestly say that the game is in the
best place it's ever been and the
changes coming in year eight look to be
phenomenal from a balancing and player
experience standpoint see just pretty
much 180 from where it was two years ago
make no mistake infrastructure matters
but successful Esports have always been
born from a natural impulse to play and
eventually compete as long as people
want to play and again Siege is in a
great place right now they'll want to
watch others play and indeed grind
anyway that's all I have for you today
thank you to everyone who came up to us
at the event and said hi it meant the
world to me I was very happy to make new
friends see old ones met people in
person that I'd never met before just an
all-around incredible and heartfelt
weekend for Siege
I can't wait to see you at the next one
I was standing outside the media Lounge
waiting for bolo so he's standing there
with pojo man who's like his long time
like support because they're together
like kids are coming up and they're
asking for autographs and they're like
and pictures and they're taking pictures
together but every once in a while kids
will be like like sort of awkwardly
trying to be like just me and Volo like
can we just do one right so right before
he comes in for the interview I go up to
bolo hey do you mind if we take a
picture like but like just like just me
and pojo and I make him take a picture
of me and Mojo